[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
should have been rich long time ago
or maybe i should have went harder never
been into b4 pallava more like shifty
green to piranhas
he goes harder not my mind and not his
father no side might never know why
margot still slash man and i don't mind
karma
proxy ain't got pack so you know it's
drama performance you ain't bad cause
you went on youtube where i want armor
just talk i wanna get faces lights in
ting but i hate her laughter
she wanna get brain cause i have them
vibes like i'm straight from guards i'll
still push back when i go link offer
cause it's packed too big for the whip
in the fence love drama most good help
but there's no answer
so i'm outside coming like god now
keep telling mommy i won't slip but this
shot could put me in the wrong strip
i should have been rick's long time ago
you know man i said that already
but it's pissing me off still beating my
shots in my face on the telly and the
mirrors froze like nellie's i need more
than nines i need bellies
keep talking mine and get henny that's a
bottle toaster man's head man chat man
once one more trap man again g don't
talk much cap if they want me eat man's
lunch and his dad wouldn't let me don't
rap much but it's one for your headpiece
i should have been smart with the piece
that i had from i never saw that picture
spent four bag street cash in a week
that's before i had in stock
i already had friends back then a latino
can i get a picture
[Music]
trying to make a statement i don't need
pagans to know that i'm this taught
friend lily half your squad been lying
shotting them half state prof my guy
from the chains they're tired
bro trap like all of his license watch
your shots get socked like a dozen
should have just got off your ass cause
you just lost steven ryan but it went
hot but i'll keep on buying i ain't got
time to be waiting
told that sergeant to let me go cause i
ain't got time for a statement
lift that trap without half of all when
i went in from always waiting for that
charge they put me down this black rock
brother i'm half caucasian stop being
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
racist
you